[Music]
what the [ __ ] is up with that poster
Pandorum okay so we had two sci-fi
movies opening up this weekend and I met
both of them with soso low expectations
but I did have lower expectations for
Pandorum than I did with surrogates but
I actually enjoyed Pandora and I
absolutely did not think I would I'm
just as surprised as you are
I mean who knew I'd walk out of the
movie theater having had a good time
with the movie Pandorum but I'm sure a
lot of the enjoyment comes from the fact
that this this sci-fi horror film set on
the hugest [ __ ] spaceship on earth
and it is enormous we're talking
citywide [ __ ] and the movie seems to be
about 99% devoid of CGI now that is
old-school and yeah while watching it
the movie just feels gritty wet grows
and just saturating but it adds to the
sickening feeling that this ship is
supposed to give you and yes well there
are some useless parts in the movie in
the end you walk out of the movie and
you enjoy it
I don't it's if I can phenomenon so the
story goes Ben Foster and Dennis Quaid
wake up from their stasis sleep with
temporary amnesia on board the biggest
ship ever which is of course in deep
space and out of power in which Ben
Foster then goes on a loan campaign to
the ass end of the ship to restore power
to the reactor thus restoring power to
the ship which shortly thereafter you
realize that he is the bravest [ __ ]
human being on earth or space because
he's quickly met by these creatures that
look remarkably like imps from the video
game Doom in fact they look a lot like
imps from the video game Doom they look
just like the imps from the video game
Doom I mean in a simplest way I can put
it I can say that pandora feels like how
the doom movie should have felt like but
I do think in this movie Ben Foster
definitely gets the short end of the
stick because while he's off knee-deep
in the dead running from imps Dennis
Quaid's locked safely and comfortably in
the control room sitting pretty living
the dangerous life talking to Ben Foster
on a walkie-talkie that's right general
Hawke go ahead and sit pretty
Corinthian leather chair there while Ben
fosters one em claw away from becoming a
full-course meal at the dead space diner
yeah way to earn your stripes there
douchebag and yes the movie does seem a
little long and I thought the
explanation of what the Imps actually
were was a little lacking and unn
fulfilling but I'm over that now so it's
not like some big disappointment that
stays with you for weeks months or even
years but I'm gonna be the greatest Jedi
ever and Master that's right because
whenever I can I will the movie even had
one of those oh [ __ ] didn't see that
coming kind of moments at the end which
is actually hard to do nowadays a lot of
movies try it and a lot of movies fail
but for some weird-ass reason this one
actually succeeded with me surrogates
had a bit of a twist in it figured it
out in five minutes
like literally burn fifteen minutes
it'll be the same with you too so if
you're a fan of gory wet survival horror
in space then give Pandorum a try you do
owe it to yourself ever since the rock
that's a horrible movie [ __ ] that movie